there are degrees of madness and the
matter you are
the more obvious it will be to other
people most of my life i have hidden my
madness within myself
but it is there charles bukowski
we all know this sort of madness the
sort that does not have clear source nor
diagnosis
not the extreme cases but the more
subtle kind that lurks within all the
so-called normal
we traditionally only see and call it
madness when it has finally reached its
apex
exceeding its last surface layer into
the world past one's abilities
interests or willingness to contain it
but to at least some extent
arguably some form of it is always there
we see it on the occasions when we don't
quite recognize ourselves in the mirror
we feel it when we wake up from a
strange sleep and the room is coated
with a dreamlike glaze of another
reality
we live it when we look out at the world
up at the sky
down the street into another's face and
experience a strange disquiet
that we haven't the slightest clue as to
what we are looking at
we know it when we try when we fail when
we succeed
when a shoelace snaps or a tire goes
flat
there is that cliched overused saying
often attributed to albert einstein but
was almost certainly never said by him
that the definition of insanity is doing
the same thing over and over again
and expecting different results
regardless of its likely misattribution
it is fair to accept this as at least
one accurate summation of a sort of
insanity
but if this is true it's not life itself
this
is not everything in human life an
endeavor with the goal of complete
resolution
of solace of reconciliation of control
peace or happiness all of which seem to
be and have always been
perpetually unsatisfiable unobtainable
the human project is a continuous cycle
of essentially trying the same things
over and over
and expecting different results madness
is not the exception
it is the norm
the loss of our early youthful innocence
marks the death of sanity
not because we are a saner as a young
child but because there were no
expectations for us to be
a young child spouting gibberish or
running around with his or her imaginary
friend
is not mad not crazy he is a child
an adult doing the same thing of course
is a madman
thus it is at this juncture of maturity
at which the expectations of sanity are
enacted
that madness is born it is not behavior
alone but the confined nature of how we
can no longer behave
which synthesizes this sort of internal
experience of a general madness
only when the child in us is muzzled and
clothed in a straight jacket
do we suddenly feel this madness
previously inexistent to us
we don't suddenly know perfect sanity
but we somewhat suddenly
must act as though we do what follows is
a sort of sane
insanity of life
it is likely that every one of us
experiences thoughts desires
compulsions or behaviors realized or
unrealized
that are by all general standards
dipping into some depth of lunacy
men are so necessarily mad that not to
be mad would amount to another form of
madness
wrote blaise baskal madness is perhaps
one of the few words that accurately
summarizes humankind so succinctly
touching both ends of it the good and
the bad the noble and the absurd
[Music]
the day-to-day requirements and
expectations of social living to be calm
certain patient responsible impressive
rational and all the rest can in any
given moment
go against all the likely equitable
reasons to not be any of these things
we are made out of and live in the
constant flurry of simultaneous
electrical firings and chemical
discharges
of a brain trying to map a self onto a
universe of exploding and shifting
matter
we sit at the end of this chaos trying
to narrow the ocean of time and space
into a tiny little canal
to successfully function at all let
alone impressively across a whole
lifetime
is as much of a wonder as being itself
in the first place
this world does not budget well for its
own insanity it does not consider or pat
itself well for the mad people nor the
stable person's periods or moments of
madness
the expectation of sanity arrives every
morning at 9 00 am
it awaits us in nearly every interaction
the fact that such a world
such a life expects us to be sane is
perhaps one of the most obvious examples
of its own madness
we expect the world and the world
expects us to be clear to be lucid
to be rational but that mad child is
still inside us
existing with its relative stupidity but
denied the innocence to justify it
screaming and shaking muzzled and
straight jacketed
never fully ready to grieve its own
death
perhaps then to some extent at least on
occasion we should be understanding and
forgiving
to ourselves as well as others if that
child breaks out to blow off a little
steam
if we act out of or at least apparently
out of character if we make jarring new
decisions
if we lose a little grip if we act a
little foolish
there is a wisdom in this sort of
general madness a wisdom that reminds us
that there are no right paths
no set directions no certain answers no
dumb questions
that up is down and down is up that the
world is anything
and nothing that it's not that serious
in the words of carl young be silent and
listen
have you recognized your madness and do
you admit it have you noticed that all
your foundations are completely mired in
madness
you wanted to accept everything so
accept madness too
let the light of your madness shine and
it will suddenly dawn on you
madness is not to be despised and not to
be feared but instead you should give it
life
be glad that you can recognize it for
you will thus avoid becoming its victim
madness is a special form of the spirit
and clings to all teachings and
philosophies
but even more to daily life since life
itself is full of craziness
and at bottom utterly illogical man
strives towards reason only so that he
can make rules for himself
life itself has no rules that is its
mystery and its unknown law
what you call knowledge is an attempt to
impose something comprehensible
on life
this video was sponsored by blinkist
for obvious reasons it can be extremely
frustrating to invest large amounts of
time into a book
only to realize it wasn't what you were
really hoping for or perhaps it was
but you seem to quickly lose track of a
lot of its valuable information
just a short time after finishing the
book summary app blinkist
not only makes consistent effective
learning easier on its own
but is a fantastic tool for a full range
of existing reading habits as well
providing useful refreshers for books
you've already read
as well as helping you more efficiently
determine new books topics and authors
that you might be interested in without
having to spend tons of time
reading first to find out blinkist works
by condensing thousands of complete
non-fiction books into around 15 minute
summaries
providing their main ideas overviews and
key takeaways
in a convenient amount of time blinkist
now also provides consolidated summaries
of podcasts
as well as complete full-length audio
books that can be purchased directly
within the app
if you're interested in learning more
about topics related to philosophy and
psychology
especially notions of madness and
society's relationship with the mind
blinkus has some great titles like
madness and civilization by michelle
foucault
man and his symbols by carl young as
well as many others on similar topics
the first 100 people to use the link in
the description will receive one free
week of unlimited access
as well as 25 off a full membership the
free 7-day trial can be cancelled at any
time within the trial period
again if you're interested please visit
blinkist.com
pursuit of wonder or click the link in
the description below
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
you